Before you start building
your own readme file,
let's first take a closer look at the
very sections that make a readme useful.
For this example, we're going to
be taking a look at Ledbetter,
a project that's maintained
by GitHub itself.
Now, I don't really know
what Ledbetter does, but
that's not what we're looking at here.
We're looking at the language that's
being used in this readme and
the parts that make it up.
A readme should provide just enough
context to get a user up and
running with your code.
Keep in mind, we are writing this for
other humans.
We'll start with a title and
a description.
A sentence or two will work just fine,
but be sure to capture the spirit of
your project clearly and concisely.
This will help frame the reader's
experience when going through your
documentation.
If you're feeling extra fancy,
you can include your project's logo,
if it has one.
Next, include any information
that is absolutely necessary for
understanding your code.
This may be dependencies
on other software or
libraries, installation instructions,
common usage, or known bugs.
It's worth mentioning, once again,
that there's no formal standard for
what a readme should look like.
Don't feel pressured to make your
readme any particular length.
Some can be extremely short, while
others will need to be much longer.
It just depends on your project.
The important part is that
you communicate clearly and
concisely any information that
is essential for the user.
And that you don't make any assumptions
about what the end user already knows.
It's up to you to decide what is and
isn't essential information.
A few good questions to ask yourself
include, what are the exact steps that
need to be taken to get this
code base up and running?
What should they already have
installed or configured?
What might they have a hard
time understanding right away?
Often, developers will include a,
getting started, or
installation section,
to help with any initial setup that may
need to happen before using your code.
If it's helpful, include example code
to better illustrate your end user's
proper usage of your code.
It's important to be mindful of
the assumptions you make about what
the user's expected to know.
Remember, you're familiar
with your code already.
So think about it from the perspective
of someone who's never seen this before.
For instance,
if I were making eggs Benedict and
my recipe called for a poached egg,
I might be alienating new chefs by
not explaining what a poached egg is.
Ultimately, the amount of detail that
you choose to include is up to you.
But for particularly difficult concepts,
it might be a good idea to
include some extra detail.